[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
HEATHER THOMPSON
RIVERA: Thank you,
guys, so much for coming today.
I'm really excited
to have the privilege
to interview Minerva
today onstage.
So give it up for
Minerva, you guys.
We're really
excited to have her.
[APPLAUSE]
So Minerva, it is September.
Can you believe it's going to
be two years since Mayor de
Blasio announced your
appointment as New York City's
first ever CTO?
MINERVA TANTOCO: Yeah.
So that was-- well,
you'll have to excuse me
because I want to take
a picture of all of you.
This is like the coolest thing.
You should be so--
I'm so inspired to see
all your faces here.
And it's just so exciting.
So I'm sorry.
I'm going to be a
tourist, and here I
am at Google with all of
you here, and with you.
[LAUGHTER]
HEATHER THOMPSON RIVERA:
You need to do a selfie.
MINERVA TANTOCO: Oh, wait.
Oh, yes.
We'll do that.
OK.
Now we can start.
HEATHER THOMPSON RIVERA:
Wow, you are so humble.
MINERVA TANTOCO:
It was really one
of the most surreal, kind of
crazy experiences in my life.
This was at the 10th anniversary
of New York Tech Meetup
that my appointment to the first
ever Chief Technology Officer
was announced.
And for me, leaving the 30
years in the private sector--
I started my first
software company in 1985.
It was an artificial
intelligence company.
And I was a junior,
actually, still.
I still had another
semester or so to go.
But I went to the West Coast
to start my first company.
And then to fast forward
and see this really tall guy
talk about someone and realizing
that he was talking about me
as the first ever CTO
was just incredible.
And I've always
wanted to find a way
to help have a bigger impact, to
have a platform for the issues
that I care about-- to improve
the diversity in technology.
When I started in the '80s,
there were only about a third
of the class were computer
science majors who were women.
But then I looked up 30 years
later, and it was like 10%.
And so that was kind of going
in the wrong direction for me.
And so the opportunity to
have a platform for improving
the numbers of women
and people of color
in technology, to be able
to influence and have
an impact on the greatest
city in the world, New York,
and really to kind
of be able to say
that the first chief
technology officer was
a girl from Queens who
went to all New York City
public schools, Bronx
High School of Science.
[CHEERING]
And I'm fond of saying if you
want to know what a CTO looks
like, they look like me.
And they look like all of you.
HEATHER THOMPSON
RIVERA: That's awesome.
Looking out at the women,
I heard a few cheers
when she said the
Bronx High schoolers,
and so I'm wondering,
how many of you
are kind of early
in your careers?
A few years out of college
or kind of just starting out?
OK, a few of you.
So maybe it would
be great if we could
gain some of your pearls of
wisdom for these young ladies
here.
You've held a series
of different roles
in your career, everything
from product manager
to strategist to team leader.
And so when you think
about these women,
is there any particular
role that you would
suggest that they pursue first?
And how do you
think about pursuing
one role in one
industry and really
diving deep into that
as opposed to getting
a more diverse portfolio of
experiences and companies?
MINERVA TANTOCO: Yeah, I think
that's a fantastic question.
I think for me, the
secret is I actually
didn't follow the path
I thought I would be on.
I sort of let the path find me.
I've invented every
job I've ever had.
The founder of Manageware
didn't exist before.
And it was just because
I went into college,
and I wanted to be a doctor.
That was actually the
plan laid out for me.
But during the course
of studying psychology--
in particular,
neuropsychology, because I
was interested in
brain science--
I started to use computers.
And then I discovered
that you could program
computers to think, possibly.
And what is thinking?
And so that's how
I got interested
in artificial intelligence.
So I just sort of
pursued the things
that I thought were cool.
And so later on, we
started the AI company.
We sold it five years
later to what was then
the largest software
company in the world,
a company called
Computer Associates.
And just kept
following the things
that I was interested in.
But most of the
time, I had an idea
of what I'd like
to move on to next.
And so when I decided that I
wanted to be a chief technology
officer, really drill into
more technical topics,
I sort of laid out a plan.
I needed to learn about
all the different domains.
And so I had this
rough idea in my head
that I'd want to get into--
after being in software
architecture, that I
wanted to understand
network infrastructure.
I wanted to also
understand databases.
Then I moved into
mobile technology,
which is kind of a
strange combination of all
of those things.
And mobile architecture
was just happening.
And then still trying to improve
on my artificial intelligence
background, which
now is a thing now.
It's come back after 30 years.
And so I did have the
idea that there were areas
that I was weak in or maybe
didn't know as much about.
I'll tell you one quick story.
While I was at Merrill Lynch--
this was about 10 years ago.
I had just finished the very
first mobile application
for the investment bank, it
was BlackBerries back then,
2003, many years before
the other mobile phones
were invented.
And I did such a
great job there,
they said, yeah, we need you to
redo the whole data warehouse.
And by the way, the last two
guys that tried to do that
failed and were fired.
HEATHER THOMPSON RIVERA:
That's encouraging.
MINERVA TANTOCO: And it's
also crashing right now.
So why don't you go
ahead and do that?
And every fiber in my
body was like, no way.
I don't know enough
about data structures
or running a data warehouse
or business intelligence.
My own mentor at the time
said, that's the poison pill.
Don't do that.
And so I really
thought about it.
And I thought, you know, what's
the worst that can happen?
So here was a chance
to really take
on something I'd
never done before,
really doing more
operational stuff,
running a data warehouse,
globally running the reporting
team, as well.
And at the same time of
running the operations,
re-architecting and redesigning
an entire new data warehouse.
And because it was
a burning platform,
we were able to do it.
We did it in 18 months,
on time and on budget.
And back then-- I didn't
realize it at the time,
but that gave me a huge
leg up in the coming data
science and big data that
was to come 10 years later.
And so I have no regrets.
Obviously, I wasn't
fired or anything.
And really built, probably--
they still use it today.
I still keep in touch with
those folks from back then.
So I guess in short, I would
say definitely have a plan.
But you don't have
to stick to it.
You know what I mean?
If you find something,
if you find another turn,
it's a little bit like walking
down a New York street.
Maybe you have a general
direction you want to go in.
But if you stop and
look around, you
might find some really
cool things that's
a little off the beaten path.
HEATHER THOMPSON RIVERA:
I'm so glad to hear
you say that because it gives
me a little bit of confidence
in the approach that I've taken.
I've shared Minerva's
sort of windy path
and have also done a
variety of different roles.
Most of my work has
been within Google,
but it's about a lot of
different teams and things
within Google.
So great to hear that.
MINERVA TANTOCO: Oh,
you're really cool.
You're awesome.
HEATHER THOMPSON RIVERA:
I don't know about that.
MINERVA TANTOCO: I should
be interviewing you.
HEATHER THOMPSON RIVERA: I
still got a long way to go.
No, it's so exciting
to be in this room
with so many amazing women
here and being able to hear
a little bit about your life.
And some of the
things that I think
are really cool about
what you've done
is you've often been at the
cutting edge, maybe bleeding
edge, of some of the
technologies and everything
else.
And I think I even heard
you say that you had
created many of your own roles.
So I feel like there's
something about inventions
in your background
that keeps coming up.
And I would love if you could
share a little bit about how
inventions have played
a role in your life
and even, potentially,
how they might
play a role in the life
of many of the women here.
MINERVA TANTOCO: Absolutely.
I think women are
problem-solvers, right?
Am I right?
We're born that way.
And so to me, the saying
that necessity is the mother
of invention is true.
But I also think
that my version of it
is mothers make the best
inventors, actually.
And so for me, a
lot of what we were
doing, especially a few
years back when we were-- we
ended up with one of my teams.
We were searching and
searching for a solution
about how to manage
complex workflow processes.
So there's a lot of
things that don't happen
in a stepwise fashion, and
the answer to one thing
might change the path that the
computer sequence has to go in.
And we were looking and
looking for this tool.
And it didn't happen.
I drew out how it could work,
if we had such a system.
We were looking for it.
And when we discovered
that, you know what?
We kind of just invented this.
And this is how we ended
up with four US patents
in intelligent workflow.
Because we knew what the
solution was supposed to be
or what we needed the tool
to do and designed it.
And then we were like, oh.
We've invented it.
And the word invention comes
from the idea of finding,
discovering something.
It's not actually making.
It's actually you've
discovered something.
And that's what's been so
great about being an inventor
and just being in an innovation
mode my entire career.
HEATHER THOMPSON RIVERA:
That's interesting.
And some of what I heard you
say there, too, is kind of,
we didn't necessarily
know what we were doing.
We kind of figured it
out as we went along.
And I often hear-- I hearken
back to some of the TED Talks,
and you hear about fake
it till you make it.
And I think another
kind of take on that
is that nobody really
knows what they're
doing when you get down to it.
There's a lot of things,
especially in technology,
that we're all going on to
try to do for the first time.
And so how can you be expected
to know what you're doing
if it's never been done before?
And so I think that's
also a good message for us
to repeat to ourselves as we
think about being put into kind
of challenging
situations, and how do you
navigate through them?
And I know you've had some
challenges along your past,
I'm sure, that maybe you could
enlighten us a little bit, how
you've overcome some of those.
MINERVA TANTOCO: Sure.
I mean, it's definitely good
to be first, I have to say.
It's harder.
But I think there's this
notion in technology
about being first
mover, but also
the idea that just because
it hasn't been done before,
you're going to have people
around that say, oh, nobody
did that before.
That doesn't exist.
All that means is you're
going to be the first
and that maybe you should be
the first to do something.
And so it's been a great journey
for me because of that idea
that if something isn't there,
that you could make it so.
And so when I was at Palm
many years ago-- early 2000s,
actually, about
16 years ago-- it
used to be that
you have to connect
your personal digital
assistant to your computer.
And then you downloaded
the data through this wire
to this handheld device.
And then you'd be like, ooh!
Look at me!
I'm so cool with my
data on a little device.
HEATHER THOMPSON RIVERA:
So mobile, right?
MINERVA TANTOCO: I'm so mobile.
Right, exactly.
HEATHER THOMPSON RIVERA:
You're connected to this wire.
MINERVA TANTOCO: And
my team was like, boy.
I wonder if we could do
this without the wire.
You know, like, over
the air, we called it.
OTA, Over The Air.
And people were
like, you're crazy.
You're fired.
But we persisted.
And we figured out, oh, OK.
Well, there's this new
thing called Bluetooth.
And there's this cool
new thing called 2G.
Well, before that it
was just G, I guess.
I don't know.
And so we did that.
And that was seven years before
the iPhone was even created.
And so yes, in fact, people
thinking you're crazy
is probably a good sign.
And that's what I
love about technology.
And so I would
pursue it with all
of the sense of
play and creativity
that you can bring
to this career.
And that's just such a privilege
to be part of an industry that
is in everything now,
including in government, which
is why I joined the New York
City government after 30 years
in tech.
HEATHER THOMPSON
RIVERA: Yeah, and I
have a sense that when
you were coming up
with these different ideas
and trying to kind of put them
in front of people, it took
a lot of motivating others,
right?
And I assume that there's
probably a high likelihood,
if Palm was anything like Google
is, where you don't necessarily
have these people reporting
directly into you.
And so you've got to
figure out how am I
going to get this
idea across the table,
get it accepted, when
all of these people
don't actually work for me?
Can you tell us a
little bit about how
you developed that
ability to sort of manage
by influence and maybe how
some of us here in the room
can develop that capability?
MINERVA TANTOCO: Yeah.
Another great piece of advice,
especially for the CTO role,
because chief
technology officers
typically might have some
engineers reporting to them.
But they don't have sales or
marketing reporting to them.
They certainly don't
have the budget folks.
And so 90% of your
power is going
to come from outside
your organization.
And I think that just having
influencing skills generally
really is helpful to everyone,
no matter what your role.
But it's especially
important when
you're trying to
get folks to follow
a strategy because a
strategy is just a plan.
And it doesn't mean that
people have to follow it.
You can't move people's
hands and make them type
what you want.
Well, that would be nice.
Maybe a robot.
But I think the
way I learned it,
it did start with
my first company
because I was still
a junior in college.
I was, like, 20, 21.
And almost everyone else in
the company was twice my age.
We hired them, and
they reported to me.
And I think part of
it is being able to be
persuasive by understanding
the motivations
and incentives of the people
that you're working with.
To make it a win, win, win, win,
win is always a good approach.
I think the biggest
lesson I learned
was that it's really
not about advocating
your position, as it were.
I think a lot of people
make that mistake-- like,
if I could just shout
as loud as possible,
everyone will agree with me.
Although some people
might think that.
It really is about listening
and empathizing with the folks
and understanding what
their point of view is
and figuring out a way
forward that everyone
can move in the same direction.
HEATHER THOMPSON RIVERA: Yeah,
you bring up a good point
there about just listening to
other people's perspectives.
And that kind of
reminds me of the fact
that there's just a
diversity of perspectives,
oftentimes, that you're
trying to pick up.
And I wonder if you could
speak a little bit to the fact
that we often hear that we
should have more women or more
minorities at the table.
And I'm not just talking
about kind of C-level
or in the boardroom,
but actually there
day-to-day, making the decisions
that drive the company forward.
And I'd love to hear
your perspective
on why you think it's
important for a company
to be more diverse.
MINERVA TANTOCO: Again,
that's definitely
one of my deepest passions
and one of the reasons
I took this role and have
been active in a lot of women
in tech initiatives
throughout my career
once I realized that I had
the ladies room all to myself.
[LAUGHTER]
It's nice, but,
you know-- I think
that there's a few factors.
It's not just about fairness.
We recognize that women-lead
companies outperform the S&P
500 by three times.
So it's a proven fact.
Look it up.
It's all on the web.
A diversity on the board, a
diversity of perspectives,
is just good business,
as it turns out.
On top of that, we just in New
York have 300,000 tech jobs.
It generates $30
billion in wages.
The US Department
of Labor published
that there will be
1.4 million tech
jobs available in the next
four years, by the year 2020.
And yet we only have a pipeline
to fill 29% of those jobs.
So if we're not tapping half
the talent of the country
to fill those jobs, then
our very economic survival,
our competitiveness, is at risk.
So I think what we're
seeing now is, first of all,
tech is in everything, and
tech should be for everyone.
And so as not to be totally
gloom and doom, some
of the initiatives that
we've done in the city
to promote more diversity in
tech-- it was actually just
in this building a little over a
year ago that someone asked me,
how do we get more
girls to study coding?
And I said, well, we should
probably have it in all the New
York City public schools.
And now, last October,
Mayor de Blasio
announced our Computer
Science for All,
which is an $80 million, 10-year
program to offer computer
science education to every one
of those 1.1 million school
kids.
[APPLAUSE]
HEATHER THOMPSON
RIVERA: Awesome.
MINERVA TANTOCO: We also have
the Tech Talent Pipeline,
which is a unique program
that aligns industry-- meaning
employers-- with the
skills that they need.
And we find students who can
learn and take up those courses
and actually end up in jobs
within two years of starting
in the Tech Talent Pipeline.
I think we're in
our fifth cohort.
It was started as a pilot--
a small, $10 million pilot.
And the United States Tech Hire
program is modeled off of that.
So that's going national.
And I have the pleasure
of announcing--
so do we have Black Girls
Code in the room today?
So one of my favorite
organizations,
they target young black women
from the age of seven to 17.
It's San Francisco based.
We can announce
today that Google
has agreed to give Black Girls
Code a permanent home in New
York, right here
in this building.
[APPLAUSE]
So I want to thank Black
Girls Code and Google
for all the work they're
doing to improve the diversity
of the tech industry.
HEATHER THOMPSON RIVERA:
I appreciate that.
We're super excited.
And do you feel like there's
enough being done already?
You've just rattled
off quite a series
of initiatives and things.
But do you feel like
there's enough awareness
and enough of a spotlight
on this topic generally?
MINERVA TANTOCO:
I don't think we
can stop until we think
of coding as a girl thing.
I love to say to companies,
when I talk to companies--
I recently talked to a
bunch of venture capitalists
who came in to look
at tech companies.
And I said, the best way
to hire more women is
to hire more women.
Just do it already.
So I don't think we can stop.
I think we've got a lot of
momentum and a ton of support
from the private sector, from
governments, from federal,
city, and state levels.
But we've got to keep it up.
We want to create a tech
sector here in New York.
We have the number one
spot in CrunchBase,
which is the TechCrunch
database, for the most
women-founded tech
companies here in New York.
Number one in the country.
HEATHER THOMPSON
RIVERA: That's huge.
[CHEERING]
MINERVA TANTOCO: So I think we
have an opportunity here in New
York to create a tech
sector that is for everyone
and is more diverse and more
welcoming, and therefore
better than all the
other tech sectors.
HEATHER THOMPSON RIVERA: Yeah.
I love hearing that because
I think there's always
that rivalry, I
guess, if you will,
between the different
tech centers in the world.
And I certainly feel the New
York versus San Francisco one
quite deeply personally.
I've lived on both coasts
as a result of my work.
And I think there are elements
of each of those tech sectors
that are really interesting.
But I think what is so
special about New York is just
that diversity that we have.
It's the fact that when
I walk down the street,
I'm hearing lots of different
languages around me.
I'm encountering a
lot of different types
of people in my day to day.
And I think that really can
help people spark ideas.
And I think that's
why I'm really
interested in the startup
space in New York.
And I know, having founded
a startup yourself,
I wonder what you think
about women in startups?
And how do you see that
going forward in New York?
You mentioned the largest
number of female founders.
But what about just
some of the folks here?
How might they start
to get involved?
MINERVA TANTOCO: First of all,
women tech founders rule, OK?
[APPLAUSE]
It really is that I'm just
living the dream here,
being able to work with
so many great women
techies and women founders.
But we're also looking
at the whole ecosystem.
We want to create
more angel investment
in women founders
and more access
to capital, more
access to technology.
And so for those of you who
have a great idea and you
want to develop it, there
are a ton of opportunities.
You should definitely check out
our website called digital.nyc.
That's sort of the one-stop
shop for all things tech.
They've got all the
hackathons and classes.
If you want to meet
other founders,
there's all kinds of startup
events over the weekend.
So a typical hackathon
might be people
pitch their ideas on a Friday.
Then on Saturday, develop the
idea, develop a presentation,
and maybe do a
little prototyping.
Sunday, you're coming
up, finalizing, maybe,
your business plan,
your monetization plan.
And then there's a
judging, usually.
And then the winner
gets something cool,
plus bragging rights.
And they have those every
weekend in New York,
a ton of them.
So I think the best
way to learn anything
is to just go ahead and do it.
And it's also a
fun social event.
There are hackathons
just for women, as well,
and girls hackathons and high
school hackathons and NASA data
hackathons.
And so if you want to
get into data science,
there are some
really great things
to do there-- the Museum of
Natural History, the NASA data
one, and then the New York
City BigApps competition,
which is the largest civic
hacking competition around.
So there's so many fun things.
And it's really just like,
get up off your couch,
go and put a name
tag on, and try it.
And you will be amazed
and inspired by the people
that you meet.
HEATHER THOMPSON
RIVERA: I'm sure.
Judging from the looks
of you guys-- I mean,
this is quite a
turnout for a Saturday.
So I have a small sense
that you guys might not
be too afraid of putting in a
few more hours on the weekend.
So that sounds like some
great ideas for these guys.
I think the other
thing that I've
noticed as I've kind
of looked at startups
and I've looked at the different
functions within startups
and then also at
the public sector
is just the trend, the
growing trend, towards CTOs
in the public sector.
And I think whether
it's somebody
like my former boss, Megan
Smith over at the White House,
Sarah Wilkinson, who's
in the UK, or you,
I wonder how can we
foster more of this
and exposing more people to
what it's like to be a CTO?
And how do you start to take
those initial steps to get down
that path?
Yeah Of course,
I'm biased, but I
think CTO is a really,
really cool job.
I mean, there are tons of
cool jobs in technology.
But I think what's interesting
about the CTO role is
it's always the intersection
of the technology
with the business
that you're in.
So my first ever CTO job was
in 1997 at Grey Advertising.
So we have this idea that maybe
the internet thing might have
some impact on advertising.
HEATHER THOMPSON
RIVERA: Small inkling.
And you have to imagine a
time when-- again, in '97,
it was just a couple years into
the web, the world wide web.
And people didn't
have fast connections.
And so if you wanted
to download an image,
you could watch it
download a line at a time.
And we had this cool idea that
you could click on an image,
and it would take
you to another site.
Wow!
And so that created
this opportunity--
it was the first
ever CTO at Grey--
because it was like, wow, this
may be an entire new product
line here.
You know, the click on a picture
and go somewhere product line.
And so that was sort of my first
kind of exposure to the idea
that you could take all
that technical knowledge--
and clearly there was
a lot of technology.
We later developed ways
to track the clicks
and blah, blah, blah.
I don't need to bore
you with all that.
You probably know--
but also to do it
in the service of
creating revenue, creating
new products with it.
And so similar to
12 years earlier
thinking about the
artificial intelligence,
and then how do you
create a product with that
and sell it to people
who will pay money for it
and things like that?
And so what I love
about the CTO role
is it is very much
rooted in engineering.
But it's also understanding
what the applications of it are.
And so when you apply
that to government
or when you apply
that to society,
that's when you get
into the good stuff.
So last year-- and
we just started
to put them in-- we were turning
all New York City's pay phones
into free Wi-Fi hotspots.
Anybody use a payphone?
It's good for, like, hiding
from the rain, I guess.
People put their coffee
cups and stuff in there.
HEATHER THOMPSON RIVERA: They
still have one at my gym.
I can't figure out
why it's still there.
MINERVA TANTOCO: Well, we can
turn it into a hotspot for you.
HEATHER THOMPSON
RIVERA: That'd be great.
MINERVA TANTOCO: So
that's a cool application.
But even more importantly,
just providing more access,
providing more opportunities
for people to use technology.
And how can we help
change society,
really, truly
democratize society
by providing more
technology for more people?
HEATHER THOMPSON RIVERA: Yeah.
And one of the things that
I love about technology
is just the flexibility
that can come with it.
I mean, you know very well from
working in the mobile industry
and everything just
sort of what that
has enabled us to do as humans.
And I know I caught a glimpse
of your daughter over there.
And I was just wondering,
how has technology
helped you do all that
you do, whether it's
in your role as a mother or
in your role as CTO and all
the hobbies and things
that I'm sure you
have outside of all of that?
MINERVA TANTOCO: Yeah.
I mean, I like to think,
and there's-- I don't want
to embarrass her.
But it's funny because they
story that I like to tell
is that the day I found out I
was going to be offered the CTO
job, I also found out that
I was going to have a child.
And that was 17 and
eight months ago.
And I was really struck
by-- I was just stopped.
I was wondering,
should I take this job?
Should I take the
big tech job and try
and be a mom at the same time?
And luckily for me, I talked to
a really good friend who said,
why are you even choosing?
You're going to
be great at both.
I don't know if my
daughter would agree,
but-- and so later
on, I realized
that I wanted to be
home in the evenings.
And at that time, you
had to be in your office
to get your email.
And so I thought,
I've got to figure out
a way that I could check my
email securely from home.
And then later,
that turned into,
how do I get my email on
a phone, also securely,
so that I could go home,
make dinner, and then do
some work after dinner?
And so that was
one of the projects
that I did very early on and
how I even got into mobile tech
originally, was so that I
could have the flexibility
to still be able to do work,
take meetings, and do emails,
but pushing a stroller in
the park at the same time.
So in many ways, being a mom
made me a better technologist,
and not the other way around.
HEATHER THOMPSON RIVERA: I
think that's a great message
for people because too often,
I think people kind of can get
hung up on feeling like
they can only do one thing
and do one thing really well.
And I think that
you're a prime example
of being able to do a lot
of things really well.
And so I encourage all
of you to take that step
and to kind of really
put yourselves out there
when you're faced with multiple
things to take on at once.
So I'd love to ask you a little
bit about the recent tech
awards that were
hosted in New York.
So can you tell me about some
of the people that were honored
that night?
MINERVA TANTOCO: Oh, yeah.
This was an incredible,
inspiring event last week.
It was the first ever
Diversity in Tech awards.
It was sponsored by
Code Interactive, one
of the great nonprofits who
are providing coding courses
all around New York
City public schools.
And the honorees were amazing.
One honoree was CSNYC,
Computer Science New York City,
which was founded by
Fred Wilson, who's
one of the partners at
Union Square Ventures.
They are the city's partners in
the computer science for all.
So it was a combination of this
public-private partnership that
made it possible between
the Department of Education,
city hall, and CSNYC.
And they were one of the
recipients of the award.
One of my favorites
is Julia Geist.
She was a student at the
Tech Talent Pipeline.
And she is now an
engineer at WikiHub.
So she also received
an award because it
didn't take her long to feel
like she also had to give back,
just two years in.
So there were some
amazing folks that night.
It was sort of the cap-off
to social media week.
But it just showed
how much support
there is to provide more
opportunities to more
people and all of the
great organizations
that are in New York that
are out there to help.
HEATHER THOMPSON RIVERA: So
how are we doing on time?
I think we may want to start
to wrap up so that we can
save some time for questions.
So maybe I'll close on
something forward-looking.
I'd love to know what is your
vision for the New York City
tech community in the
next five to 10 years?
And then, when you even think
beyond the next five to 10
years and you're
thinking about, what's
the person who's sitting in your
job, say 15, 20 years from now,
what do you hope
are the problems
or challenges that they'll
be solving at that point?
MINERVA TANTOCO: Yeah.
I think we're seeing some of
the seeds of this amazing future
of New York City already.
One of the biggest
trends, I think,
is the notion of
social innovation,
that is, tech for good.
Because being a woman in
tech and being a coder
is a superpower.
And we need to use our
superpowers for good.
How can we use technology to
help the poorest among us,
the immigrants, the
people that have no voice?
And one of the
privileges of my role
is I get to see all the people
that are making that happen.
And so, yes, it's OK to use
tech to sell a few more pencils
or, do you want some socks
to go with those pencils?
Whatever it is.
But to be able to use
those kinds of technologies
to really deliver government
services where they can
do the most good, to
come up with new wireless
technologies that
will expand broadband
to the digital deserts,
that is really taking hold.
And I think New
York City really is
the epicenter of a
lot of that activity
because it's an ecosystem
of social do-gooder techies
that are all meeting and
percolating together.
When we think about the
city streets and the idea
of a connected city, again,
I see a huge opportunity,
where right now we have a lot
of the personal technology.
And sometimes, that has the
effect of actually alienating
us from each other.
We're there, but
we're not there.
You know, that photo
of everyone at dinner,
but they're all
looking at their phone.
Like, are they at
dinner together, really?
Or are they just sitting within
a few feet of each other,
but doing something
someplace else?
HEATHER THOMPSON
RIVERA: I saw a couple
on a date the other night
that was very much like that.
I was like, I'm pretty
sure they're on a date.
Neither of them was
talking to each other,
and they were both looking
at their phones for, like, 30
minutes while we were
just kind of passing by.
So I completely understand
that concept of alienation.
MINERVA TANTOCO:
And I think that we
can have a notion
of technology that
actually connects us better.
And there's no better place
than in sort of public spaces.
So yes, we're going to have
the self-driving cars that you
can call up with your phone.
That's all going to
happen, for sure.
But also, I think we
have an opportunity
to say, how can we connect
the virtual and physical
communities to
connect to each other?
And how do we make
our streets safer?
How do we use technology
to band together?
I've seen a lot of apps
that are like, well,
who are the homebound
folks in your building?
And maybe you could bring
them food once in a while.
Or in an emergency, how we get
together and help our neighbors
who might be flooded out.
And so I think we
have a real, not just
an opportunity but
a responsibility,
as folks who have
this superpower,
to really figure out the
vision of New York City
as a smart and equitable
city, a city whose heart
is as big as our brains.
HEATHER THOMPSON RIVERA: That's
an amazing picture and kind
of painting in your head to
go off into the world with.
So I know I for one am
very excited to continue
to work here and be able to
experience life in New York
and work in New York.
And I'm really
appreciative that you've
given me some time to get to
know you a little bit better.
And I feel like since I've
had the privilege of asking
all the questions, maybe
I should turn it over
to you guys.
And so if you guys
have any questions,
feel free to go up
to the mics, and I'm
sure Minerva would
love to answer.
AUDIENCE: Hi, everyone.
My name is Maureen.
I am a [INAUDIBLE] advisor.
And I've got, actually,
two questions.
I'm going to keep
it really quick.
The first is for the audience.
Rarely do you ask
questions to the audience,
but just by a show of
hands, how many people
here came to obviously
meet new folks
and hopefully collaborate
on different projects?
Just by a show of hands.
We know you've got
full-time jobs.
OK, cool.
Awesome.
And Minerva, can you talk
about artificial intelligence
and some of the use cases for
some of the top companies?
What are they doing with
artificial intelligence,
now and in the next five years?
Thanks.
MINERVA TANTOCO: Oh, cool.
I love the geeky questions.
Thank you for that.
Oh!
I love geeking out.
So when I started 30 years ago,
the biggest change between then
and now-- and people
ask, why didn't you
continue with your AI after
you sold your first company?
And the truth is that
between 1990 and 2000,
it's called the AI winter.
Everybody was
really disappointed
that AI didn't deliver
what it promised.
And all of the
venture capital for AI
dried up during that decade.
So I found other
stuff to do, clearly.
But now, we have an even
more powerful opportunity
with artificial
intelligence because we
have three main factors.
One, we have massive compute
now because of the way
that we can do.
We were working on--
this well before even
the 286 was invented.
So I won't bore you, but we
had to basically turn a crank
to make the computer go.
And secondly, we have
massive data because before,
we couldn't compute
all that data.
And now we've got
massive data from which
to apply the deep learning to.
And the third big
component, of course,
is the massive connectivity.
So 30 years ago, it
was pre-internet.
And those three things
are the magic sauce
that's now why AI and just
sort of intelligence systems
generally is finally
coming into its own.
And so what I see
is a future not
of replacing human
intelligence, which
is what artificial
intelligence means sometimes.
I think of AI now as an
intelligent assistance.
It's going to allow
us to really process
all the crazy amounts of
data because now, we're
spewing terabytes of
data every few minutes--
my watch, the phones,
everybody's phone
is spewing out all kinds
of data and information.
So I think we can use
intelligent assistance
to help us make humans
smarter instead of trying
to replace what humans do.
AUDIENCE: Great.
Thank you.
HEATHER THOMPSON
RIVERA: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name's Kelby.
I'm from Florida
State University.
I'm a sophomore.
Just a quick question
regarding women in tech--
so there's something that
you said that kind of really
spoke to me.
And recently, I went into an
interview with a tech company,
and the interviewer
was like, well, yeah.
You're a woman.
That's part of the
reason why you're here.
And I was like, hmm.
He's like, no, no, no.
You're qualified, but-- and
every time somebody says "but,"
they don't mean what
they said at first.
And it is a common theme here
to get more women in tech.
And you want to see
more women in tech.
However, do you feel that
there will come a day whenever
there's too many women, and men
suddenly become the minority?
And how do we stop that because
one thing that's very important
is that women are
underrepresented in the tech
field.
And everything
that's being created
is all by a male's mentality.
So by getting women in and
being able to collaborate,
we have both sides.
But do you think there
will ever be a day where
women become too much?
And how do we stop
that from happening?
How do we get to
the perfect 50/50?
MINERVA TANTOCO: It's such
an interesting question
because I don't know if the idea
is to be this perfect 50-50.
What I look at as my parents and
grandparents grew up in a time
where being a woman doctor
or being a woman lawyer
was a big deal.
I look forward to the time
when it's just not a big deal.
That it's just like, yeah, woman
doctor and woman technologist.
So whether that's a percentage,
it's much more cultural,
this idea that-- I think
we're right to bring attention
to it now because
it's clearly an issue,
economic and fairness,
for both those reasons.
But also, my dream is
that, yeah, you're a baker.
You're a mom.
You're a crossfitter.
Oh, and you're an AI scientist.
And so that's my vision
of where things can go.
And I hope that events like
this sort of make it OK.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much.
MINERVA TANTOCO: Thank you.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: My name is Stephanie.
I'm a student at the
Flatiron school right now.
My question is we've got the
New York City digital map.
We've got open-source data.
What piece of technology
that will make for a more
cohesive, accessible
city are you
most excited about right now?
MINERVA TANTOCO:
You mean besides
the free Wi-Fi hotspots,
which is pretty cool?
HEATHER THOMPSON RIVERA:
People have actually
talked about moving
their offices,
I think, to the bus stop
because the Wi-Fi's better there
than it is in their
office or their home.
MINERVA TANTOCO: Yes, exactly.
Exactly.
I was talking to
someone who was like,
I'm going to have a business
where I just rent chairs
for $1 next to those things.
But I think that some of
the cool-- so you're saying,
what are some of the cool tech?
Well, I'll say something that
my team worked on last fall.
We just launched a beta.
So what's also
exciting is that we're
able to innovate in government.
Those are two words
that a lot of people
don't usually put together.
Beta test is another one.
So we took some open
data and decided
to expand it to make
it easier for residents
because we realized
that open data's great.
It's fantastic.
But not everyone's
a data scientist.
I'd love that to be the case.
So we created this thing
called neighborhoods.nyc.
And what it is is you
go to neighborhoods.nyc.
You pick your neighborhood.
And you get all of the
most popular open data
feeds by neighborhood.
So you could look
up chelsea.nyc,
and it has the alternate
side of the street parking.
Everybody loves
the health ratings,
including the restaurant
ratings and rat
sightings and the garbage
pickups and all that.
Because we looked at what
was the most popular one?
But it didn't come
in a localized form.
So we partnered with one of the
winners of BigApps, Vizalytics.
And now we're trying it out.
So please do try the
neighborhoods.nyc.
Find your neighborhood.
We hope that we can add
more and more content
with communities
getting involved.
So that's really exciting.
That link between the physical
and virtual communities
is sort of the thing
that we're driving for.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
That's actually on my
very long list of apps
that I've started brainstorming.
So I'll definitely check it out.
MINERVA TANTOCO: All right.
AUDIENCE: And I
won't build my own.
MINERVA TANTOCO: Cool.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I'll move
on to something else.
Thank you.
MINERVA TANTOCO: Thank you.
HEATHER THOMPSON
RIVERA: And I think
I'm getting the signal back
there that we have time for, I
think, one more question.
So you'll be our last.
I think the good
news is you guys
can come and find us afterwards
if you want to ask a few more.
But please, do us service.
AUDIENCE: Sure thing.
I'm Meghan.
I'm a senior developer.
We talked a lot today
about getting more women
into the pipeline.
But something that I've
found just in my career
is that keeping women there
is just as much of an issue.
And I was wondering
what your thoughts were
around that, and whether it
could come from the government
level, trickle-down,
or if it needs
to be within the
organizations themselves?
MINERVA TANTOCO:
Yeah, I'm with you.
I think that I also focus a lot
on the mid-career female tech,
as well.
Because like, oh,
you're going great,
gangbusters for those
first 10 years or so.
And then you hit a bump in the
road, like, oh, I'm pregnant,
or whatever that is.
And you might seriously
consider dropping out.
And I think that's when
you need the intervention
from the company, from the
mentorship, and programs
for women to come back
from maternity leave.
The idea that you
could have flextime.
And I love the idea that
paternity leave is actually
a big feminist issue.
I think that's really
important, too.
And so for me,
what really helped
me was all the great support
and mentors that I had.
It's hard.
Any job is hard.
But sort of being that
lone unicorn in the room
is even harder, and you
feel a lot more pressure.
And I guess I'm here
to say, there's so much
support out there for you.
Don't be afraid to ask.
Don't feel like you
have to go it alone.
And you'll be
amazed and inspired
by how much help you
get because everybody
wants you to stay and succeed.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
HEATHER THOMPSON
RIVERA: Awesome.
Well, guys, thank you
all so much for coming.
And Minerva, thank you so much
for spending some time with us.
MINERVA TANTOCO: Oh, thank you.
It's been an honor.
HEATHER THOMPSON RIVERA: Great.
[APPLAUSE]
Awesome to meet you.
MINERVA TANTOCO: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]